how's it going my name Matt welcome back
to the wonderful game called Bali
let's bully some people shall we you
don't like bullying what is wrong with
you actually that's probably the right
appeal now with all the men taught sting
and all that stuff that's a bit awkward
isn't it starting with that Hey
that's what we're doing on this chat out
facade both awkward Thanks
I should probably add it down this video
I should fix it in editing it's in the
future I never get mad very anyway we
gotta go over here because it's the only
question rates XJ Banzai [ __ ]
naylet all right let's do this fun it's
the only quest Italy the only quest we
have I don't like this building oh [ __ ]
we gotta go to class
oh it's a tagging one I've been wanting
to do that I've been meaning to do this
one nice but hey it looks like
are they waiting have way to greet your
new boss Harrington yay wow the new buzz
hmm ah no no that oh no sir no massive
boots
grand master kiss listen boss those
grease monkeys are making life very
difficult for gourd
that's because gourd was showing one of
their girlfriends a good time some
leader you turned out to be father says
leadership is about looking after those
you lead uh-huh you taught me that right
before you laid everyone off
what a really bad message all over their
dirty little slum
why should I yeah wash you're the boss
exactly yeah I'm the bomb the ball go
send the message I'm the boss I'm the
boss
spray paint like a bow it's so old I
think anyway yeah all right
all right sir I will do that after this
360 nailed it it's my girlfriend let's
see what she's doing I got Fred hi hey
sexy hey how you think I like it bud
what's a girl gotta do to get something
come you want my pin is that it oh she
wanted chocolate what if I dip my penis
in chocolate would that be better
is that true it's so great come here
look I think I'm in love you should drop
the chocolate mmm I love your boots
there's some pink and awesome I'll
remember this forever
you remember this forever how about
that's forever oh man it wasn't me swear
to god it wasn't me oh [ __ ] me why do I
always got to fail my quest alright we
go to class I go back to the quest good
day everyone
I never actually been named geography or
geography teacher uh-huh I know you're
all enthusiastic and ready to learn I
think I think in high school geography
was probably the most fun class because
our teacher was just really good oh [ __ ]
if I don't nail this this will be
embarrassing seriously and it's [ __ ]
Finland don't [ __ ] with me I'm afraid
it's wrong excuse me sir I'm pretty sure
I know where the [ __ ] Finland is oh [ __ ]
France
yeah oh my god it's [ __ ] back
all right a party god no way that was
Spain whoops oh [ __ ]
it's like I've been there spotting up as
I go offend my offense Ukraine it's like
here somewhere Oh
I'll deal with it in a second switch to
learn your [ __ ] there Italy
that's where I am
have you been a pizza slicer Greece is
over there Pola oh [ __ ] this is where it
becomes awkward
I know Ireland Romania Ukraine and buff
[ __ ] ah [ __ ] ah [ __ ] me all right Gus I
mean I know that I know that [ __ ] which
one is it try again
[ __ ] heaven what it was right you that
idea and what's right you charted a fine
hopefully I did not offend to manifest
what with my hey I knew them I knew
literally all of them you can't say I
didn't know them you can say but you are
wrong if you say it because I was right
I was right I was right the game was
like wrong
the game was wrong that was great yeah
about what I'm good to it that all the
rest enough anything you don't know what
I'm up to dawn what what it what is he
up to I think a thick plot twist all
right listen
let's take the quests again and then and
then we'll go at a town to tag those tag
those things Oh for the de quest is
still there I knew that one I know that
one I like that they actually do
exercise that would be a lot of fun if
there was actually school stuff I don't
know actually not now I think like but I
don't know it would be fun for you bros
to see how good I am in this thing I
don't know I don't I'm not very I don't
know what's called English when you know
things in general not very that like I'm
and I don't think I'm that knowledgeable
I guess that that's that word but I
still had a and have good grades in high
school but a lot the last years I myself
is that any way to greet your new um I
got pretty much well whatever I don't
want to brag why we gate but yeah go to
school I don't I don't even when I
didn't even finish my universities
honestly just getting good grades was
just pointless it was more like I wanted
to prove to myself that I wasn't an
idiot
it's the only reason why I actually
started and once I actually got into the
school that I I just went I felt like I
went to university because it was the
normal thing to do you go to university
that's what you do but it wasn't what I
wanted to do and I guess that's how I
started making YouTube video that was
his board of boarded University and I
wanted to start I wanted to do what I
wanted love to do and I never thought I
had this as my job and I know I'm not
gonna have it forever but I think it's
it's good experience that it's it's fun
why not do what's fun in life you know I
don't I don't know that's what life is
all about isn't it what do you think
about this hey what's the meaning of
life
that was very deep I was extremely deep
did you hear that
get rich or die trying' that's just how
it is all right lay down your tag oh all
right let's see let's see how my tag
looks like Jamie was here that's so
serpent and the pink it's already there
right away now that's all right all
right
buy some oh I got a more spy much spray
pen Oh like a Santa Claus what's up
Santa you gotta say hi to him hello
hello hello right [ __ ] here how's it
going how's it going Sarah but I love
you Santa I love you well I'm gonna
throw in this Apple BAM
hahaha oh no no no no no I was just
kidding I swear [ __ ] me I was just gonna
go in the store when I was ignorant see
um all right finally house gun it's not
a chicken on this wall that's very fresh
very nice all right let me just grab
grab some spray paint hey hey
any time a man any whoa that's a lot of
places that needs tagging all right I
guess we're doing this greaser suck yeah
[ __ ] greaser good yeah that looks
good but greases don't all right let me
land another one
let me line another sweet tag I love how
all of them are in the same pattern that
I have to [ __ ] Oh instead of
cheese balls grease balls ha ha ha ha ha
what kind of missing ha ha ha take a
bath Grizzard take bad because you smell
didn't get it late last night again oh
man
for man for man I like cars and bikes
cuz I can't deal with big we're
harassing them on a psychological level
I love it
ha ha ha ha ha alright what's next of
the [ __ ] same [ __ ] padded take
that crap out of your hair
you greasy scab I cannot do agree with
that one actually I don't get why how
they think it's nice when you have
greasy hair
they're looking at a [ __ ] wall
who could ever call this I what a weird
bugs through again Jimmy comes all right
nice hair grease bags I'm gonna keep
doing that as long as you have spray
laid out education for something how's
that your education anyway all right now
we unlock the ton of questions are you
excited
oh I can see your tap pants are just
tingling lovely right which one what do
you want to do next you want to do one
in front of me ha ha ha quite splendid
choice indeed
yeah all right let's see what let's see
what this one oh wait sorry I'm a Santa
Santa how are you how you doing hey
Greaseballs I don't want to [ __ ] with
you shut up Lola's raised what the [ __ ]
is this of course I love you Johnny no
you know love is complicated then seem
complicated between you and that Gordo
kid oh yeah Ronnie please we've been
over that he's sweet but it was so
innocent
get off yeah I love it when you get
angry Johnny I really should get ugly
too stupid be still hey Jimmy hey what
are you doing here looking for you
Johnny at Lola's house yeah be nice to
each other huh you know what I like
about you too you're both so straight
forward so quick to judge so fast
ain't no one felt like me real are we
gonna raise now Jimmy in a race
definitely yeah I heard he was pretty
fast this little twerp give me a break
oh I think we've got a little challenge
I just love challenges they make me so
excited well I'm gonna get laid oh all
right
remember we laid a wheel with
thank you what the hell did he say the
[ __ ] do you say all right I'm getting
kind of tired of races but a man's gotta
do what a man's got to do when if man's
gotta raise a man's got a race and if a
man's got a race a man
stop never twice never quest never sweat
devil twice nipple twist air nipples
with air nipple twist now a [ __ ] whoa
what the [ __ ] this is hard to control in
shape level 20 nettleton nipple twist
what the hell is going Oni I'm late cat
Hills I need a win deal oh [ __ ] it's
only one lap to passage em a path that
we have to win the race we have to win
don't run stop nipple twisting make out
my nipples aren't in my face all right
here we go
now we're talking baby now we're talking
number one by the [ __ ] is number one
number one [ __ ] [ __ ] what'd
you say hey don't eat it first checkup
Oh bag of marbles can I possibly throw a
bag of marbles BAM
oh that smells like your mama dad man oh
oh oh no no [ __ ] are you no way
I happen to my [ __ ]
shortcut IIIi got going I gotta get
going
faster faster [ __ ] [ __ ] out of truck
couldn't you come on this is clearly not
my race quite clearly I'm Emily dead
look at my health and I never died in
this game what's the point of the health
bar honestly seriously pointless job
bank Oh [ __ ] please back stop
punching me I'm gonna die I died there
is a point I forgot there's payback
coming Oh someone's gonna die from this
all right so we finally finished this
quest holy [ __ ] there's a lot of cups
for one guy vandalizing a house Oh a
[ __ ] he givin got me even got me grabbed
baller I got you [ __ ] the police [ __ ]
the police [ __ ] [ __ ] the pool I don't I
don't know that song alright anyway we
finished divequest it seems like we have
a lot of like unfinished quest to finish
and it don't you love that don't you
love unfinished quest oh you do well I'm
glad we shared something in common I was
just thinking here maybe now I don't
have enough things in common man in my
pain but yeah I'm glad we though let's
do the quest over there in the Aqua
berry store I never understood exactly
what it is I'm supposed to do there and
I never actually did it because I
thought it was kind of boring but it
seems to move on to next chapter we have
to fit are you crazy
we have to finish it great sex tape Oh
[ __ ]
alright let's tag this place
well this one is difficult I only like a
rich paper because my parents are
judgmental your poetry capitalism scam
very nice 360 aqua Barry store is closed
oh it's this one where we defend that
stupid Kooks date
I just never understand how you climb
the [ __ ] tree hide in the tree okay
I'm in the tree I just need to get up
don't get how I get up there we go or or
what's about that alright so here's the
day's coming that guy is a lucky man go
on a date with a hot woman mm-hmm all
right so people are gonna come in this
time why they're so evil why will they
come and disturb her they all right in
the ball it's always really awkward when
when teachers date I don't know how many
[ __ ] kids are interested in teachers
dating come on that and not already get
winks it brings a baseball bat you think
that's appropriate
oh no the visions are back back Elfi oh
come on gorgeous it's about time I show
you what I know about chemistry ah
and a little biology ha ha ha best quest
ever 50-buck that is indeed bad Jimmy
huh sorry buzz but it looks like I will
have to end this episode here but like
and favorite if you enjoyed a lot
subscribe comment today and I'll see you
in a cafe over I love you rose stay
awesome
well I'm pretty sure even animals could
drive